it feels like just yesterday that
Samsung took the stage with some very
fine actors to unveil the galaxy s4 and
to declare almost everywhere you looked
the next big thing is here but that was
last year's next big thing this this is
this year's next big thing I'm Joanna
Stern and this is the galaxy s5
Samsung's newest flagship phone with a
new camera a water-resistant design and
actually a heart rate sensor on the back
but does this thing actually capture
your heart I've long said that the
previous Galaxy phones have been weighed
to plasticky the galaxy s5 feels a lot
better it's still made of plastic but
it's now a matte plastic with a nicer
design it comes in black white blue and
of course now gold no it's actually
Johnson & Johnson they're going for
their band a design that but there's
another neat trick in the design so
water-resistant absolutely so the galaxy
s5 actually features in the IEP 6/7
ingression protection rating which means
it's dust proof and then also a
water-resistant can do up to a meter of
water for 30 minutes absolutely xiaolin
but one of the biggest changes comes
with the camera now is a 16 megapixel
camera and Samsung actually says it has
the world's fastest autofocus one cool
new feature is called selective focus
it's meant to give you a nicer portrait
by focusing your subject and blurring
out the background the way an expensive
lens would my instagrams our goal is so
much better than yours
oh well the phone also has a fingerprint
sensor for unlocking the phone and
making safe mobile payments through
PayPal unlike the iPhone 5 SS sensor it
requires you to slide your finger across
it which could take some added practice
if you're wondering about specs the
phone has a 5.1 inch Super AMOLED 1080p
screen just a hair larger than last
year's model it's also got a snappy 2.5
gigahertz quad-core processor but the
nice thing about this galaxy to me is
that Samsung hasn't completely flooded
the phone with loads of new homespun
features on top of Android instead there
are some new helpful features for
instance there's s-health
which tracks your exercise performance
using the pedometer and heart rate
sensor on the back of the phone and
Samsung's launching not one but three
wearable devices all which have built-in
heart rate sensors actually really
digging this one the gear v which has a
curved Super AMOLED screen there are
some other features too
like a low powered black and white mode
for saving battery and a kid's mode and
then a private mode for hiding your
secret correspondence the Galaxy s5 will
be arriving in April no word yet on the
pricing though it should hover between
200 and 250 dollars on a contract we'll
have a full of you closer to them so you
can find out if this really should be
your next big